if I can touch on that essentially the
sum of water work is doing when my team
and I are essentially trying to build
personalized AI teaching systems that
are able to map the sum of human
knowledge as it's being released online
and to essentially optimize personalized
lesson plans for each given individual's
mood as it changes in real-time the unit
learning styles we envision the future
of Education looks something like kids
playing a video game the computer games
will react to their moves to optimize an
engagement they're not gonna want to eat
his bathroom - anything else play this
game but they're gonna be learning
mathematics physics calculus we see the
number of hours kids are already
spending on video games and say that the
past couple hundred years of pedagogy
sciences it's not really a science more
in part teachers come up with hypotheses
and then putting it into the classroom
of really small data feedback with non
wrapper capable experiments so what
we're trying to do is essentially build
data that correlates human behavior
using biometrics with how do we interact
with media how do we interact with each
other and rebuild a large enough
critical mass of data that lets us begin
to use unsupervised analysis to model
what are the matter variables that
govern human engagement human learning
how do emotion stress anxiety there are
personality types your political bias
all the different things that quantifies
a human what is your heart rate and all
the different biometric and personality
inner external nature and how do these
correlates with actions behavior in
response to an extremely diverse set of
attention economy assets like film media
online courses so the idea is by
understanding how do people react in
general then we can begin to optimize
performance someone's opinion may
contradict yours what is my friend Alan
it's all about your
who are we in what is the nature of this
reality what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host on Sathyan we
are still on site in the beautiful
Vancouver British Columbia in Canada we
are now going to be talking about AI to
optimize human performance and much more
we have been tam drawing us on the show
thank you about having this really
wonders where to talk about the work my
team is doing thanks so much for coming
on the program Ben and I'm really
grateful to Andres for slan for
introducing us oh yeah Andrea's and his
company called New Zealand's doing some
really cutting-edge works yes so I said
mutual acquaintances exactly lots of
them lots of them we have so many usual
friends yeah it seems like I'm pumped
and I'm so pumped to dive in with you
Ben's background for those who don't
know is founder of Atlas Holdings which
is an AI company working on emotion
technologies using human data to
optimize human performance you can find
all the links in the bio below Alice
holding stop fund neuro tech XCOM as
well as a LinkedIn profile then let's
start things off with a big picture
understanding of you know who we are
what's really going on in this reality
where we're heading so it seems like
humans are immersed in this exponential
technology age it seems like AI is
eating our world and it seems like the
most upstream issue that we can try and
get to is the education of children is
trying to make it so that children when
they're born into the world have deep
feelings of interconnectedness with
other humans and with nature but they
understand the nature of this reality
that they can figure out what their
North Star is and pursue that bringing
their gifts into the world
tell us about how you see that equation
and how what you're building is helping
catalyze that process now that's a
really excellent way to begin the
conversation because we do live in a
time as as many as of us in the tech and
general entrepreneurial industry knows
it's really catalytic time where we have
really two paths that humanity can go
down one it's a bright beautiful future
where everyone is empowered or another
is a really new clear fireball and
depending on what the actions of our
leaders do today it's really going to
catalyze one of these visions or another
so we think about things on a first
principle basis what issue must need to
thrive and be happy and first of all
most we need to survive we need to be
able to overcome the hardships that
nature throws at us the the window ring
a shelter got food and we do live in a
society today where much of these
resources are provided through a
particular system and structure but what
we're heading into a new world is we're
gonna see increasing levels of
inequality we're gonna see higher levels
of job optimization through AI it's just
gonna be a bigger social attention to
social and ease and what is the best way
to ensure a more stable prosperous human
race and an integral in the planetary
species
I believe rather than using AI to
centralize and automate small working
that's naturally the way things progress
but what if we use AI and all these
revolutionary technologies to empower to
not just the weakest links in society to
strengthen the whole chain so to speak
but how do we use technology to
essentially structurally change the
system the idea is that in a world where
with sufficient education or able to
master the forces of nature find a way
to get shelter food if everyone has the
means to innovate to think about what
they need to survive through weather is
through external help but ultimately
education is what what allows us to
independently not just think about our
passions but get the skills the tools
and resources to execute on them so
hopefully a future humanity if a lot of
our leaders today through our best and I
catalyzed change in the right direction
is one where people feel empowered
enough to first and foremost survive and
then more importantly after that to
think about what do you really care
about in this world and then build it
but you can't do any of that without a
sufficient knowledge base internally
whether it's engineering mathematics so
if you want to be the best chef or a
great chef you have to know the
fundamentals first principles behind
culinary so or even being a gardener I
want to be the best most beautiful
gardener artists in a road requires a
base level of education so to speak so
that's why a lot of the work that my
team is doing is geared towards trying
to solve that education problem
structurally once and for all so to
speak with by automating pedagogy Wow
okay so it's as though then let's go
with the directional arrow of
civilizational trajectory towards
prosperity for all let's follow that one
because that's that's my favorite way of
putting it is a way don't sell I'm not
selling any stories around fear only
towards prosperity only towards the in
line civilization for all so okay so now
in order to get there we need a a very
aware way of meeting the basic needs of
all people on the planet and the these
basic nutrients that are needed you are
listing some love from the people that
burnt us into the one we need love we
need air or water food shelter elect
educating these basic needs kay so the
so to build the social fabric that's
most conducive to those basic needs
being met for everyone around the world
so the democratization of those things
leveraging AI automation those
technologies to make those things as
readily available as possible okay then
there needs to be some sort of a process
for the discovery of that unique spirit
that's in that seed to fully be able to
identify what is the unique gift that it
wants to express why did it adventure
into consciousness here in this body
this beautiful piece of art called body
for it to bring these gifts forth so we
have these components that need to
happen to enable the prosperity for all
so it seems as though then there's a
moral burden an ethical burden a
philosophical burden on not only like
you gave this example of trying to get
these these links if you think of each
one of these pieces of the chain each
one of these links to be able to
actualize the ones that that have the
most resources right now if the ones
that have the most power right now have
to have the feelings of being burdened
in a sense of trying to build that
social fabric that is most conducive
towards the prosperity for all so what
do what do we do in order to get these
incremental steps in the next decade or
so that ensure that prosperity for all
well I might be a romantic idealist but
the way I see that when the universe
came about and when a big ball of energy
it is naturally the progression is to
find orders to find the most optimal way
to structure the universe in itself how
do we go from a big crazy ball of energy
into through the Big Bang to create
structures to create time to create life
and what I like what what comes to mind
is you imagine oh this is a call by
Marcus Aurelius in meditations where he
says a horse runs bird flies and a human
just does good things I think it's all
in all of our knee
naturally to think about what we feel is
morally beautiful and this means what is
valuable what is more valuable than our
own life in fact how do we rank our own
life and value in comparison to the
other beautiful things in the world and
naturally what humans do is after we've
thought about these values then we act
to optimize strategies to to maximize
these but the problem arises when when
there is a lack of opportunity to even
think about oneself in such a
metaphysical way when we are say living
on the streets or if we don't have food
or if our families are in danger we
don't even think about ourselves or
where we we don't have the luxury of
thinking about values greater than our
own immediate survival so I feel like
the question it's not how do we spark
this because I believe all humans have
that innate beautiful nature to find
morality and to live for it and then die
happy but the real question is how do we
eliminate that which prevents people
from reaching the levels of
self-actualization so so it's a really
hard problem but you know it's really
valuable one no pun intended
would you say then those obstacles are
the lack of those basic needs being met
when you don't have love you don't have
air water food shelter electricity okay
100 percent and this is why even though
I have a very strong love for capitalism
I also like you had Andrew yang on your
podcast earlier before is talking about
universal basic income where at the very
least those who are most disadvantaged
in society who don't have the very
fundamentals and the very least a system
will be there to address that I mean I'm
Canadian so I can't speak much for all
neighbors down south but thought it was
very well thought out those policy
changes and it's a really big issue
because there's no one clear-cut answer
and you're always gonna piss off someone
no matter what approach you take in
their direction
there's I think always a nuanced way to
put this
just like you began your statement by
saying that you appreciate aspects of
capitalism that have helped us get to
where we are yet we also realize that
the way that in nature we see things
like the redistribution of carbon that
is sequestered by the largest trees
through the roots and fungal systems to
the little seedlings and the smaller
trees that don't get to sequester as
much carbon that same process of
resource distribution is clearly not
evident in human hierarchies of wealth
it's just not there and we have to be
completely honest that it's not there
and then we have to build the social
fabric that makes it so that the
obstacles that you're listing earlier
where these fundamental needs are not
being met in those root systems where
they can be overcome so that people can
went upon birth have the basic needs to
identify what their North Star what
their purpose is and go on a trajectory
to get there no that's that's a really
remarkable way to put it I do agree and
that's I guess that's what makes the
problem so fun it was really easy then
it wouldn't be worth one's whole life
effort I think the best way to find a
good happy value to work towards this
one that's just great enough where it
seems like it's almost impossible but I
mean if you achieve all of your life
values by trying to optimize all the
things what are you going to be left
optimized so it's good to have a really
really hard problem to solve I think
that's what makes it fun I can't wake up
oh just is really fun and having that
humility to say oh even though one may
never win the war so to speak one must
always do our best so we've put whatever
we got yeah I mean what's the
alternative every moment going towards
that big vision in a very selfless way
that in a perspective that always keeps
in mind the hundred billion humans
before us that built civilization that
we get and that by the time that we
pass ourselves that we will be leaving
it incrementally towards justice
incrementally towards prosperity that we
lived every single day building towards
that it's paramount okay so the design
of that fabric is really about the
removal of the obstacles of removing
poverty of meeting the basic needs in
education and all the other nutrients
that are needed for the seed in order
for that seat to flower and that
requires a big moral burden it of those
at the top that are leading the big
companies that are leading the big
governments that are the wealthiest
people on the planet - and we're gonna
get to this in a little bit in our
conversation on the way that you're
collecting people's biometric states
that maybe it's important we've talked
about this on the show quite a bit to
see those those are the people of the
greatest power to be able to map how
much empathy do they have how much
spiritual awakening do they have how
much deep ability to interconnect with
other humans and nature and really smart
they all right yeah because if we can
measure those states and then prove when
someone does not have those states maybe
we can incrementally nudge their them in
those directions of gaining more of
those states and then be able to see
that in their biometrics and then their
decisions towards redistributing those
resources for empowerment rather than
for self dealing and conspicuous
consumption we'll actually see that
happen you know that's a really good way
to put it because when we choose who he
wants to elect and who do we want to
follow it's important not just to know
their their thoughts and what they speak
is important notice subconscious so
being able to leverage biometric
technologies always with ethical consent
is important because it lets you get an
insight into a person's feelings and we
make most of our decisions most of our
actual purchasing power purchasing
decisions and general
sessions and life based on what
intrinsically feel every time we are
dealt with a a topic that might be
sensitive or or just any topic in
general all the logic has been processed
in our prefrontal cortex and process
into language and then we have the issue
of speaking but limited of their pure
emotion that pure visceral gut feeling
it's lost during the translation of
language I mean I can smile and I talk
with like a an excited tone but what's
really happening underneath if we want
to have a true excess of transparency so
I guess the you needs like the leader is
you've got it it's gonna be important to
highlight this level of information for
all the stakeholders
you know democracy and around the world
no that's that's a really cool cool
topic yeah I love this topic and it
requires people that are building the
biometric technologies with give them
ethical consent like you're indicating
yeah is really important to not just do
things legally but above and beyond that
what is moral what is the principle way
of doing things in collecting such
sensitive data yes I'd love to touch on
that we will yeah we're gonna get we're
going to important to talk about yeah
yeah yeah and the actual text acts that
you're building to do so okay so this is
kind of the big picture vision is
getting a empowerment for every single
child to be able to unleash their
fullest gifts to remove those obstacles
make those basic needs met around the
world and then maximize that prosperity
through that through that way and I also
really like the perspective of having a
we for some reason we decided that my my
partner or my your partner all of our
partners our spouses whatever you want
to say they basically become everything
they have to be your emotional support
they have to be or you know your workout
partner they have to be your spiritual
partner they have to be your business
partner they have to be your everything
for you
[Music]
which puts a huge burden on on on each
other when actually a good amount of
that can be offloaded to aí and aí coach
that knows you actually better than your
partner doesn't in some ways and that
actually can nudge you in the direction
of of working out or of or reading those
couple of dozen of pages that you have
to get to you know etc and that helps
with those trajectories towards
unleashing the North Stars and I like
your focus on AI coaches for every
single seed that's pretty much screwed
into the world yeah
ultimately the limitations of a teacher
no matter their natural brilliance in
being a good teacher is limited by the
amount of knowledge that they know like
I cannot teach what I don't know I
cannot learn from someone who doesn't
know what they're talking about but with
an AI and approach were able to
essentially map human knowledge
crowdsourcing or really specialized
knowledge sets and give this access to
to AI algorithms to be able to learn
more effectively than a million teachers
could I think Google just released their
quantum braced chip as pioneers quantum
supremacy which which means that they
can start processing and acquiring and
analyzing data much greater greater
speeds and imagine ever not to digress
but a brain is has quantum phenomenon
happening in it which is cool cool
digression yeah so I love that big
picture focus it's such a vital part of
where we're heading in our future and
then ultimately this becomes a data
science problem is the automation of
optimal pedagogy on the child's
direction towards their Northstar yeah
if I can touch on that essentially the
sum of what our work is doing my team
and I are essentially trying to build
personalized AI teaching systems
are able to map the sum of human
knowledge as it's being released online
and to essentially optimize personalized
lesson plans for each given individual's
mood as it changes in real-time the
unique learning styles we envision the
future of Education looks something like
kids playing a video game the video
games will react to their moods to
optimize their engagement you're not
gonna wanna eat in the bathroom do
anything else but play these games but
they're gonna be learning mathematics
physics calculus we spent we see the
number of hours kids are already
spending on video games so right
thinking why don't we automate the
process of teaching into a video game
format and use the most cutting-edge
emotion sciences to to try to present
this content and not just the way that's
engaging but optimize for a person's
unique learning styles so each one of us
should have a one-on-one mentor like we
as humans we evolved to speak face to
face like you can see my emotions change
in real-time and then you can tailor our
conversation to optimize my our
engagement but we've really lost this in
the industrialized revolution we're like
we got one teacher to 30 students who
doesn't know the way one teacher can can
track and personalize the lesson to
every student and it gets even worse in
a digital age of one teacher to like a
million students so using using
technology we can actually bridge back
that gap but this is an extremely
extremely hard problem to solve because
it requires a bunch of unsupervised
approaches unsupervised machine learning
approaches to map human knowledge and
it's optimized personal lesson plan so
what our team recognizes is that before
we try to build a an AI based solution
we have to recognize that it's a data
science problem which means that you
have to have a sufficient amount of data
to optimize any algorithm with so our
business model which is important to
keep in mind not just a theory about how
do you do sustainable dominant
businesses that
you reach your goals so a business model
today involves helping other enterprises
work of human data making human data
easily accessible for humans and all
must be done with ethical transparency
above and beyond what is hidden in the
Terms of Service so it's very important
to think about these ethical concerns as
we source data because ultimately while
working with technology saying I
tracking facial tracking brain wave data
heart rate data these are super personal
data sets and we have a to rules in our
company for any product and we build the
first is extreme transparency rather
than hide acquisition of data legally in
the Terms of Service like some other big
companies might do we are philosophy is
to make sure that any user who's gonna
be giving us their data knows Dharma in
the marketing so there's no step of the
interaction with any companies that that
sort of hidden you never want someone be
taken by surprise and the second is to
ask ourselves if we build this
technology do I want my little brother
I'm a little sister using it and then
once it matches those two criteria I
find that there's China does generate a
semi semi foolproof way to approach this
you know always looking for better ways
to do things more ethically and in a
more philosophically sound way but yeah
acquiring data and working with with new
alternative data is it's important and
think about the future ethical concerns
and execute him today rather than just
sort of run fast and break things so to
speak and in this respect yeah yeah I
think I digressed a bit there I love
that synthesis so I love your vision
with it too so all right so we have blue
to Sigma which is such an important
phenomenon so we need the one-on-one
mentorship with every single one of the
young people that's right actualize
their gifts clear not 1 to 30
you but we need a one-on-one mentorship
with every single one okay and then we
need also to leverage the new
technologies like augmented reality all
these new fields that are emerging I'm
having neurofeedback towards you
reaching your goals as well this this
learning in these in these
three-dimensional spaces of play and
that's a big one as well and then we
have just this overall ability to map
civilizations knowledge try and be able
to identify at a young age when this
child is born what do they want to be
exposed to which areas of play do they
want to learn and and see what they like
and then if they like those more you
enter them deeper and deeper into those
areas and see if that's it and then they
they vie more and more identified with
their field that they want to pursue and
then that's when you know you're doing
things very ethically along this way
that the child knows the parents and
know that that the data that you guys
are working with this very it's very
it's important to be ethical and so you
you make it clear that all these
biometrics that are coming in that it's
all very transparent this is crucial all
along the process absolutely yeah I
really hit there hammer under the nails
hit I think that's the same yeah and
just what's kind of disgusting to see
today as many companies they recognize
the value of data but they don't treat
the data as as the users ownership I
think now it's good we're starting to
see a lot of awareness that your data is
your data is you should have a sense of
ownership and control over it so we just
want to take it to the extreme and treat
it not just as a property right but it's
a human right data is like it's kind of
like a universal basic asset that we can
actually get ownership of and then
potentially compensated for yeah it
could be part of that universal basic
income
is our asset of data absurd to give you
a really negative scary example there's
a company called very happy why do we
have to do the negative well as a
warning there's a ok I mean yeah I'd
like to see how this words the positive
irrational prosperity oh I understand
like the importance of giving the
examples of fear but I think it's so
much more important to guide us towards
yeah I think on the first principles
basis of the things we talked about
that's as pretty important just rutted
and sort of framing things in one thing
or another
hopefully you guys in the audience can
they know that people already know about
what is the all of these malevolent
licenses and all of the fears and all of
the panics and catastrophes and negative
potentials people have already heard so
many of those examples like let's just
focus that's true that's the daily news
right there you know it's a daily I can
I can respect that we want to focus on a
positive on the positive trajectory
potential moving forward so I my
question on this front is how do you
guys figure out how to map civilizations
knowledge using unsupervised machine
learning how do you then understand what
my you know how do you how do I play
with all the different possible edges of
of knowledge and then figure out what my
unique gift is I want to bring how do I
use your AI coach etc yeah well I think
the best way to approach this is with
humility and say that the past couple
hundred years of pedagogy Sciences it's
not really a science more of an art
teachers come out with hypotheses and
then putting it into the classroom of
really small data feedback with
non-rapid capital experiments so what
we're trying to do is essentially build
data that correlates human behavior
using biometrics with how do we interact
with media how do we interact with each
other how do we build a large enough
critical mass of data that lets us begin
to use unsupervised analysis to model
what are the manner variables that
govern human engagement human
learning how do emotion stress anxiety
there are personality types your
political bias all the different things
that quantifies a human what is your
heart rate on a different biometric and
personality
dinner external nature and how do these
correlates with actions behavior in
response to an extremely diverse set of
attention economy assets like film media
online courses advertisements not very
cool industry but very big so the idea
is by understanding how do people react
in general then we can begin to optimize
performance so our business model today
involves collecting helping other
companies in the attention economy that
already have networks to add in a layer
of emotional data because taking a step
back to build a personalized AI teacher
is a multi-decade vision yes and if we
try to launch that today there's it's a
cold start problem yeah we need a
sufficient amount of data the longship
are also building a business a start-up
and an entrepreneurial journey to create
zero from 101 from zero yeah hopefully
not the other way so the ideas our
business today involves helping
enterprises that already have networks
but could use emotional data into it and
networks to optimize it the problem is
that these technologies are rather new
facial tracking brainwave tracking heart
rate tracking so most companies they
don't have the in-house specializations
to build these solutions and to deploy
them and to ethically source them so
that's where we come in we go there and
almost do a lightening consultancy
analysis for any given company whether
it is one of our fortune 500 clients
government agencies or nonprofits and we
customize an end-to-end solution where
our engineers and scientists
think what's the best way to incorporate
an emotional data layer and then we
build on technology out there so the
idea is by being able to deploy these
emotion solutions across industries and
to build a team of talented scientists
and engineers send me a message on
LinkedIn if you guys or anyone want to
join but yeah sorry plug no please you
yeah the idea to centralize a team of
super brilliant people and become
eventually over the contracts over
clients over the years we've become
experts in working with emotional data
collecting and centralizing emotions and
human reactions to it in ethical and
politically sound way then we will be
able to solve the costar problem of
identifying how do we what type of
algorithms are best give the best
performance on this type of real-time
human data set it's like everyone's
trying to create an artificial
intelligence and that's like general AGI
but no one really understands what it
means to be a human yeah and the best
way to understand what it means to have
human consciousness across demographics
across age across a nationality across
gender is to collect the data first and
to build a business that is sustainable
so that we can eventually scale up to do
much greater things so it's like it's
almost being humble and saying oh this
is what we know this is what we don't
know this is what we can do and what we
can do it ice P the best in the world at
it which is what we call emotions as a
service I love that yeah emotion as a
service yeah a yeah it's like software
as a service on so no one yeah yes yeah
yeah instead of SAS yeah I I love how
you put it as a emotional layer that has
to be applied to governments nonprofits
from fortune 500 companies just around
the world an emotional layer so
basically all of the
data that's coming in from the internet
of things smartphones AR blah blah blah
on most cars it's coming from everywhere
now there's got to be some sort of a way
to measure my mood my emotional state
from all this data and then be able to
like I'm like a very like a very easy
way of like if there's a way to get my
my heart rate variability or my my eg
just as there's a ways to simply get
these pieces of data or just having the
sensors in the room etc all these
different places IOT that can then do
things like Alan you were sensing a
slightly higher stress levels so there's
now gonna be a spray of lavender into
the room or now there's going to be some
jazz music that's played or now we're
going to open up to one of your favorite
readings or videos etc take a little bit
of time to stretch and relax you know
just this is really not it is rocket
science cuz you need the big corpus of
the layer of emotion the massive catalog
to make it so that you actually know
when someone's feeling stressed or you
know when someone's feeling tired ooh
you know when they're feeling happy or
you know when they're on a really good
path of focus towards their goal and to
have that ai coach actually tailor these
experiences like you're saying you got
to build in this multi decade long
process this big catalogue of the
emotions 100% ethically like you said
but it's not [ __ ] rocket science at
the same time because you don't need to
have all these scientific reports about
nature therapy being good for people to
know to just get out of the tiny little
rat cage cubicle and go to the trees go
to the beaches go to the places where
you will feel like you are
interconnected with everything I think
the reason why we are loved in these
suboptimal frameworks as we grew up in a
society where we really emphasized IQ
productivity rationality but we're not
taught almost never
in the public education system to use
our EQ to develop a heart to develop our
internal sense of how do I feel about
this maybe that was not not what I mean
in the industrialized era you know
people are trying to turn our cogs in a
machine so the whole education system
has been really geared to get people to
think externally about and try to be a
productive member in society grow your
IQ but we've all the lack of any
emotional training like any self mastery
and yeah you know this I'd love to talk
a little bit about one of the social
impact projects were working let's do it
regards to emotional self mastery I love
it because I saw a llama has made this
one of his crucial points as well as the
emotional self mastery yeah why is it
not being taught at the first moments of
birth on on that'd be a great person to
partner with I'm sure we can learn a lot
from some of the meditations and
philosophies that they've developed one
of the social impact projects they were
working on is how do we help recently
release incarcerated individuals or
people who are currently in the prison
system get a better sense of self
mastery and our solution is personalized
guided meditation to help recently
released inmates they're in halfway
houses or even in within the prison
system itself it's a very vulnerable
population yeah and how do we give them
the tools they need to to stop and think
and go explore themselves internally and
to ultimately get a better sense of self
mastery I mean we could all really use
that to be able to develop our own
internal fortitude so to speak and so
even though the technology can be
applied in almost every single industry
and that emotional data layer we have to
ask ourselves what is what a society
really need the most right now and above
and beyond profits and revenues how can
we work on really game-changing products
that can potentially alleviate the
suffering of countless people I mean the
big reason why
most people are incarcerated to begin
with it's not through their own fault it
is through trauma and abuse and neglect
as children that's what the statistics
and experiments and studies show and
being a being incorporated within the
prison or within the prison system
there's really very little Avenue to
break out of that circle I call it a
revolving door because people leave the
prison system and inde don't have the
resources the skills the support they
need to to break out of that trap you
know that there's self-defeating anger
and trap you're providing the
intervention at the most critical time
where it can alter their trajectory out
of the revolving door and towards their
Northstar yeah absolutely so yeah what a
great thing about working on self
mastery tools is we are all humans
whether we're incarcerated wherever
student whether we're in old age by
building the same core principles of
optimizing person's self-awareness
giving them feedback on your own neural
and physiological behavior we can
translate a lot of these learnings and
product features from say from the
prison industry into the education
industry into the mental health industry
so like many ways to understand and
optimize a human perform them like I'm a
human I don't even know what it means to
be a human
that's how tricky the problem is it's
like a meta on meta or meta yes yeah
okay so it seems as though when we take
in the mass amount of data in terms of
emotions and what it means to be human
in this grand scale what it how we can
basically log biometrics and emotional
states and show which biometrics of
heart brain etc have to do with which
dates of emotion so it's big catalog
then the when you have the I coach
making the recommendations for people
it's making it based on a very strong
catalog of states where it knows that if
these are the biometrics that are being
shown then it means this state and if
this person feels like they want to get
closer to their north starting the state
and I will provide this as an
intervention right now that's the
feedback loop yeah and a I guess brain
will be thinking what is the probability
given a current state of the inputs what
is the probability of the decision
making is going to optimize and
performance what is learning a
particular subject or learning a
particular skill this is just a human
brain can't process all that data and
yeah and not and then do it's Caleb Lee
that's why we have the algorithms that
already know us better than we know
ourselves I don't know where I was a
month ago
I don't know where I was a year ago I
don't know what I eat a month ago when I
don't know Google knows Facebook they
just know and I don't I don't know who I
was messaging that day I don't know what
I was messaging down don't know what I
want to buy I want to buy the emotional
sentiment as well regarding all those
messages right when I was messaging you
what was my emotional sentiment etc
being able to parse that through I know
P I mean there's so much data there that
I'm not aware of and are like you said
our processing systems aren't just
capable but let's let's get to this the
emotional layer itself is you're already
starting to work with companies that
that want you to embed so you're doing
like a custom a custom built build-out
for those companies to build in the
emotional layer ethically with them and
then taking the data from there to build
out the big catalogue absolutely earlier
and we select our clients extremely
exclusively we have to make sure that in
our right philosophical fit because we
don't want everyone to empower any firms
who don't add
core dedication to protecting their
human users privacy so what we
specialized for our clients is white
label turnkey for end-to-end solutions
using whatever technologies they feel is
best what that we after all analysis we
prescribe a certain amounts of
strategies that they can embark on
whether it's use eye tracking facial
tracking brain wave data heart rate data
so every clients a unique Beast and I
think the best is to is to think hey if
the clients business was my business how
do how how do we optimize from here
given the technology and the skills and
it's hard because any time a client
anytime a business in general once the
work of any one of these technologies
they have to hire a PhD are going to
spend months and potentially years
developing and testing a product or or
working with an external consultancy
that ultimately ends up owning all of
the code and now giving them the
empowerment so what we what we do is we
go in there and we we do my own
consultancies and we develop white-label
turnkey solutions to empower their brain
and power their users
so we're taught Atlas Holdings because
it's a pretty boring name and like
there's a saying that you can go really
far if you give out of people to credit
and oh yeah everything's your fault when
it goes wrong and nothing is your credit
when it goes right that's how to be a
good person well I think we all have to
ask ourselves are we are we building
something for the credit already
building something for impact for what
transcends us for the rest of humanity
that's and if that's the answer then you
will have great support from others and
I'm not so sure if your audience members
have read Ayn Rand's book Atlas Shrugged
whereas she talked about she's a
philosopher in the 19th century where
she talked about what happens if the
most productive people in society shrug
the weight of the world because Atlas
was a Greek god that carried the world
on his shoulders right
but I don't think that's always the best
way to approach things
so if Atlas Holdings it's almost like a
symbology Co tribute Iran but also to
say hey what happens if the most
dedicated people in the world saw that
it is worth it to to do what they feel
is best for the rest of humanity does
right it's a good good Northstar exactly
yeah yeah let's Holdings that talks
about the burden Atlas is also a big
catalogue of all of the emotional states
and and the biometrics that are
associated with that but it's also that
the it is upon the ones that have the
most especially around the world to be
the most benevolent in maximizing
prosperity moving forward and I want you
to give a couple of these analysis you
listed these things called you know
facial tracking facial recognition are
eye tracking facial recognition I'm
emotional sentiment how do you as much
as you can can you give us an example of
where you're making the emotional layer
at a company oh absolutely
why don't I talk about razón of is the
world's first automated platform for
focus groups so Rhino focus groups are a
really big industry but to run a focus
group you have to send a bunch of ads
hire people locally brilliant to
laboratory physically and to and then
you pay them about 16 bucks an hour to
scan their emotions and you normally do
this through another company so it's a
very long process to get a focus group
running so what we've done is we built
an app where we hire about 600 to 700
biometric freelancers that get paid to
download our app and then get paid to
watch videos as we track their emotions
in real-time so it's a way for people to
sell us through mutual consent
there are facial expressions the eye
tracking they know exactly how much
money or how much money they're you know
and it's their choice to say oh I think
it's worth my time like a dollar an hour
or seven dollars an hour depending on
the content on how engaging the content
this so essentially what we do is we
have decentralized and fully automated
the process of the focus group industry
and this lets us deliver a human
attention minute per dollar and I put a
hundred times - a thousand times less
than our competitors it also allows us
to do really interesting things like
analyze the emotions of crowd behavior
around the world versus traditional
focus groups and research groups and
traditional neuroscience whereas focus
to one demographic so one thing that's
interesting is we can see how different
cultures react to say racism yes we can
see in North America it has a big civil
rights movement which is beautiful
because when we show racist imagery to
people in North America almost across
the board it's just big frowns growls
like that's not cool that's not right
but we also see in countries where it is
not a very developed sense of civil
rights when racist imagery is shown
there might be a smile or aura or just
no no response as well yeah we can also
do things where we analyze gender how
different genders react to really
controversial and painful subjects like
we ran an experiment what you just said
it was so interesting because it oh we
swing albeit quite deeply into traumas
of the initial millions of indigenous
people that were here over 500 years ago
and the way that they've been killed and
displaced and then we do the transfer
and a slave trade trauma and then
because of those things and then what
happened with the southwestern part of
the United States and and Mexico and
Latin America etc we swing all the way
into the depths of that trauma and
because we do we're swinging in so far
in the civil rights direction for the
indigenous for Latin America for
Africa for women's rights for gay rights
etc the so it's so interesting that so
then we in a sense become at the
forefront of civil right it's like it's
like Oh interesting yeah being an see if
one has say been in a fight and really
beat up someone to a pulp then you can
stop and grow and reflect and say hey
look that was really not the behavior
that I want or him to embody as I grow
and evolve and find my level of moral
growth first as a man a woman who's
never been in a conflict or done things
that they might be ashamed of they'd
have no context of how do we grow as an
individual there's no differentiation of
right or wrong
yeah so I think very much having made a
lot of painful painful mistakes in the
past as a culture and the culture grows
and evolves in the finest greater
formats and it's like in an earlier
powerful conversation and the universe
tends to was greater moral others like
the same as the human mind and the human
society and the human as a as a whole so
I'm really optimistic because anytime we
make really bad mistakes as a species we
think good yeah we say like oh gotta
like move on as just move on and like
how do we well it was best for all
children what's best for the future I
love them raised by a choco taco yeah
well I I listen to that podcast all the
time he is so great that he right after
someone says something that went
horrible or miserable or bad he goes
good good good because it's all learning
experience it's all yeah I have another
point just around what you were just
talking about it's so important to bring
this up you have a way of seeing the
internal state the consciousness of the
person through biometrics you can you
can objectively begin cataloging
conscious
and so then when you see that the person
is not experiencing states of like
feelings of sadness or or or just
disgust when they see the racism
happening then you know that there is
something that's different like what is
their state of consciousness when
they're not feeling that versus when
they are feeling that so these are
different states of biometrics and
consciousness and then you want to you
know if we're trying to move people
towards a more just society towards one
where there isn't that racism where
there isn't those obstacles then there's
is some sort of a way to create through
an AI coach learning around that
evolutionary process for people so it's
just it's just so interesting basically
there's there's a Oh once you get the
states of emotion and the states of
biometric and consciousness so yeah once
my completely honest with ourselves yeah
yeah once we have that and then we have
how we want to have an AI coach not just
towards our North Stars along their
journey we have these things harmonized
and what no it's it's important because
today we see the left and the right I
see values in both approaches but
there's no conversation there's no sense
of commonality and I think the problem
is everyone has their own biases but not
everyone's aware of their own biases so
by the idea is to essentially use a lot
of our technology to create to create a
sense of self-awareness like oh you know
we're all judgmental because it was in
AI like if we just show you how you're
feeling we're not saying anything bad or
good we're just saying
here's the data you made a human
decision on there many cases so there's
a lot of directions that this can be
taken in the whole industry of emotional
technology and emotional human
performance optimization is it's in this
infancy is really really young human
optimization to human data and even at
the level of these focus groups like
you're saying I like that example a lot
it seems way more efficient getting
people paid super transparent then they
can quit a job that they don't care
about and sell their data best we
mentioned earlier data is a human right
and it's like to write to your own body
it doesn't matter if you own your own
body if you have no one if you don't
have to write to a marketplace to sell
and buy food and trade so what we're
trying to do is create a platform where
people can own their own data and
monetize on it so the future of work
might be are you sitting and watching
videos or playing games and selling your
data through consent to people can use
that for predictive analytics to track
their content creation drive their
marketing as long as it's all done with
extreme transparency and empower the end
user all the ownership of their own data
I think then is it can be deployed in a
very useful way for Humanity I will talk
about the negatives believe you guys
didn't mention dad the magnet of ways
that these technologies can be used if
they're not done with an ethical
principle and in a community I'll talk
about very shortly here attack X we
spent the last four and five years me
digging into all the different ethical
considerations
these technologies my brain-wave data
all in different biometrics can be
ethically and reasonably deployed on a
business and human sense by whatdaya
fighters to digest yet I'll get lost in
it
digression after digression we talked
about this a little bit earlier too and
I really want to know how to be able to
get these things implemented as soon as
possible you have like we were talking
about emotional states the states of
consciousness along with their biometric
states that represent them excellent
then you have the certain ways of of of
when you watch something like someone
getting physically violated that someone
feels like they're in pain themselves
they have empathy or they feel like
smiling and so what would do you you
know what do you do in that scenario how
do you how do you catalyze that
awakening for someone to feel more
empathy same thing with these global
ruling elite that we were talking about
earlier how do we map the emotional and
biometric states of consciousness to see
how much they care about other people
they care about
unconditionally they care about
maximizing prosperity moving forward
versus their own self dealing tendencies
and so to be able to make the AI coach
says recommendations towards a
prosperous future now those are some of
the examples you give the example about
about data as well being a human right
well how do we make it so that every
single person is able to take what is
their own emotion and consciousness and
biometric data and be able to decide
when they want to open those valves and
let that data go to researchers into to
doing that process of maximizing
prosperity getting you properly
compensated for having that be
transparent I mean these are the most
pressing questions of some of the most
pressing questions of the exponential
technology agent some of the most
pressing questions of
the movement towards AI coaches in
general it seems like you're taking a
really good first principled angle not
only with data ethics and transparency
but also about getting people paid for
their data rights but also about
starting with the big emotional layer to
get the best data afford ai coaching I
think philosophy is the first step but
it's useless without proper business
model generation not to sound too cliche
but if we want to execute our moralities
we have to as a business my team when I
have the challenge of figuring out ways
to get this to market to scale it and to
start making something valuable today
with with the ethics but not always
relying fully on the goodwill or
philosophies or what is nice so you have
to do so I guess to answer your question
of what how do we say make shape some of
the grow will relieve some of the
presidents some of the industry leaders
more aware of their own empathy or lack
thereof and how do we improve them I
think the first step is I like to always
say the first step to change it requires
self-awareness if you don't know you're
making a mistake if you don't know that
something yet you're doing something
because of a subconscious bias that's
always there's no real way to actively
grow yourself as an individual and
really change never comes from someone
coming from the outside the real true
change comes from when you think about
something
parent and the possibilities of what you
could be if you eliminated a behavior or
adopted another behavior but I would be
lying if I say we knew the right answer
so our first step is to sort of those
self mastery tools yeah that helps
students to how about incarcerated
people gain a better sense of self
mastery and I love that it's a really
hard problem but it's kind of fun yeah
yeah is it because you're a human trying
to understand humans oh you're a human
trying to teach an AI do I just tend
humans yes no the meta layers that
you're talking but earlier yeah again it
seems as though having humans be able to
more oh thank you I love the questions
by the way they're really really on
point and and exponential questions
thank you why do you call like this
instead of like like this oh I guess
sighs I've got Chinese ancestry so is
that what good it is a sign of respect
say hey I see it recognized you as a
person
look ones little fists and ones the palm
yeah yeah I believe the people versus
the this one interesting Wow
I just I really love just doing that
like respect
I respect the divine in you however I
can absolutely yeah yeah like I always
tried to call everyone sir or writer
it's a sister yeah me too because I find
it uh it never hurts one to give a bit
of tightness into the world yes yes I
mean if anyone ever abuses you gotta
have the strength to stand your own and
they're destroying it again
we against but but always as a natural
default it's important to yeah that
sense of respect it's like a pool that
we all drink from if we go around like
making enemies or like spreading a
negativity around we're sucking from it
yeah they're contributing water which is
kindness - exactly yeah they're a giant
we don't pull it wrong don't see a lot
of children with syphilis we talked
about several times the challenge that
we are currently at as a society in this
reality we are at this beautiful moment
of challenge is it the exact purpose of
creation or source or God or the
universe at the multiverse or whatever
you want to call it is for us to be at
this exact beautiful point of challenge
I like to think that this beautiful
moment is constantly moving constantly
evolving and the concept of God is
really to sum up all of these movements
yeah as we progress back and forth
through time so I think that things are
always the way they should be
I think trying to always imprint our
subjective perspectives on things and
say oh this is this shouldn't happen to
say something shouldn't happen is almost
self-defeating because this is just what
the reality is and as a part of that
reality we have a decision as to whether
we want to try to solve that for the
future or let these inefficiencies
happen as we see fit so it's I think
it's probably impossible for the part
like the cell in the body to understand
what the whole human body is doing but
each cell in our human body has a choice
on whether it wants to keep being a cell
I like to this might be a bit extreme
but I sometimes say that even a rock has
consciousness because if the rock didn't
know that it was supposed to stay in a
certain geometric autonomy for me
how would it remain a rock why does in
its proton just blast off and somewhere
else but no I go ahead do you do you
think that we are all one I believe that
we are all one and disconnected in the
sense that a disconnection is part of
our oneness mm-hmm dinner that we have
parts of a giant network and as a part
we have our individual autonomy or
character a subjective life perspective
but we are also alive in a greater sense
of the universe such that even after we
die we are still part of that same giant
network as is transformed saying life is
like energy when we die even if we
become a rock that rock is still part of
a greater interconnectedness and that's
enough for me
because yeah that's enough for me to to
be able to live and die happily I think
so we're all one in there's unique
essences or spirits to each of us as
well no a hundred percent yeah even a
cat or a dog or any rock in itself is a
separate entity but at the same time in
equal measure connected with everything
else so it's a is it okay a
contradiction of dichotomy yeah but
that's the way I see it within the deep
oneness and interconnectedness are
separations that can be combinatory
sized in a infinite amount of ways yeah
and our perceptions are individual
perceptions of the world really
determine what a next step of the
network is going to take whether it's a
superposition a superposition beam of
energy and when it is I guess yeah I
won't go to mush and stuff I don't
really know I don't want to misrepresent
any quantum physicists reading the
comments but my feeling is that each of
us the way we perceive the world as a
part of it
determines how we move forward and how
the network evolves and grows so my
perception understanding ourselves first
gives us a much more solid way to
perceive the rest of the world
absolutely I'd love understanding our
own consciousness face
I loved your focus on self mastery
throughout this conversation I loved
your company's focus on self mastery
being the first one of these first big
principles about evolution as self
mastery know thyself know thy North Star
and know thy steps along the way they
get there all that type of stuff 100%
and to be a bit poetic it's like Wendy
beam of energy has become self-aware
that's when it breaks down it's a
superposition and becomes something real
okay I'm gonna get flack for that one I
know well one more time say it again
when when is like as a poem you know
it's a poetic way to think about it when
an object is in superposition when it
finally figures out what it wants to be
yes when it solidifies its perspective
so to speak whether it's like a you
collapse you collapse into wonder x1
that's probably not accurate it's a nice
philosophical I agree it's poetic and
scientifically accurate so we are in a
state of superposition with our North
Star trajectory until we make the
decision to message Ben and invite him
on the show then the show happens oh
yeah yeah or to create a show like
there's like Windows cetera yeah like
when the human will is focused that's
when a lot of action and the results
will constantly collapsing the
probabilities yeah problem is when we
don't think about ourselves we remain
superposition reacting to the world
it sort of formulating and forming
something into it yeah yes yes it's like
philosophical science poetry
yeah exactly do you think that the most
upstream issue that we face as a society
in this reality is our lack of
understanding of the oneness our
feelings of separation our lack of
feelings of interconnectedness I think
the biggest issue facing our generation
is a lack of opportunities in an
increasingly unequal world where we're
going to see automation we're going to
see a digital AI revolution and we're
going to see massive populations of
people displaced and left without a
means to survive and that's only the
result of this from a game theory
perspective is warfare rioting
widespread poverty so I think the
biggest problem that we're facing is to
fix the like how do we take care of
those who really need to help because
don't who those who don't need a helper
out we're gonna find our own sense of
moral ability but it's becoming an actor
whether it's becoming a gardener but the
biggest impediment to increasing human
morality and human consciousness I
believe it's a lack of opportunities
that our current generation is moving in
the direction we're heading towards in
so this is why I'm very I'm burdened by
say people who really try to focus on
empowering those who could really use
the help
yeah so then the most pressing thing is
to be able to deliver a powerful social
fabric that is most conducive for the
actualization of all the spirits that
are birthed into it and and leveraging
that in our
that's what we want that's it yeah
that's that's it's hard problem to solve
but it's doable you know people are
aware of it no pun intended
yeah well yeah yeah I like that that
focus we can pass a little bit of time
now on neuro tech X your initiative to
make BCI's more accessible to people in
community as well as FEV your founders
and entrepreneurs of vancouver community
absolutely well what I would recommend
is anyone in the audience who is sort of
interested in biometric technology or
working with biometric devices to check
out a neuro tech X community we've got
thousands of scientists around the world
and a super supportive we just believe
in trying to provide networking
resources opportunities for anyone
interested in this really young field of
brain-computer interfaces I'm currently
trying to help us launch a marketplace
to centralize brain-computer interface
devices such that our neuro tech X
community has a much cheaper and faster
and easier way to find the right devices
for them I also helped found the neuro
tech X Vancouver chapter so it's a local
community if you're in Vancouver feel
free to join our meetup group
we're happen to be the largest in
Western Canada but what is nice is we're
all over the world and basically almost
every major city like 30 chapters around
the world so yeah I think the beautiful
thing about having a community to
support us if you ever need help
if you haven't have ideas you need to
find partnerships unify people to hire
people to work for projects you want to
build having a community around you is
the surest way to succeed in your career
and supporting and growing a community
you believe in it's rewarding yeah
and another community that that I've
found in a Vancouver's got a faff group
founders and entrepreneurs of Vancouver
kind of cheesy name but essentially
being a CEO being an executive being a
founders extremely it can be really
lonely and difficult and hard at times
so what I decided us why don't we bring
a group of us together we're about a
hundred large now with businesses all
across the range of industries and we
just get together to do like silly
things like detonate a bunch of high
explosives and only target shooting or
eating dinner or like do archery tag or
go for a wine and join so building that
sense of network growing the community
around you and really caring about how
do you grow community as value to other
members that has been instrumental in
growing say my own career yeah so I
recommend it anyone who's out there find
your community a community of people who
share your values
hopefully transhumanism and I try to
grow it I try to like give back do it
the way you do what you can yeah I love
your focus on community and the
importance of that along our North Star
trajectories is crucial so when you have
an AI coach that's assisting you along
the way it's also going to be it seems
very important to also have humans along
the way and so it's a big question of
our time as well what will be the future
with humans and given the area of
expertise that humans can do better than
general intelligence slowly shrinking
over time yeah and the good thing is and
everyone is listening to this is a human
and that means that it can make a big
change in overall if they they value and
think about what they want to do and to
do their best to do it I mean even if no
one succeeds it's still worth the effort
because that's the human spirit they
just keep doing what we think is the
best
and the most moral thing to do reach
that North Star so let's be despite the
universities I that's so crucial and
then also the way that you've been
explaining what you're doing with Atlas
Holdings is I think a really good way of
people watching or listening to think
about tackling some of the biggest
issues that are facing our world because
you're coming from such a deep first
principled way of viewing it which is
that if I want to help with this AI
coach to bring people tour the North
Stars I have to start with building the
remotes robust data set of emotions and
conscious experiences with biometrics
possible then then be extremely ethical
about and transparent about data getting
people paid for data rights all this
type of stuff at the most foundational
layer then actually doing the process of
the AI coaching and helping people get
there and all that type of stuff in
helping all these companies build
emotional layers in the process I mean
it's just a very strong way of
approaching one of these big issues you
know our team has really done our best
to optimize this and yeah so our team is
we've got some really brilliant people
helping us on our team so I can't take
any auto credit for that yeah shout out
to that 'less Holdings team and and I
also just shout out in general we need
to build that social fabric that it's
most conducive for everyone actualizing
their gifts and to make it at a time of
automation AI coming in we got to make
it happen as soon as possible
and and keep them on the positive
prosperity directional arrow
as much as we can so yeah this was
really solid yeah it's very mining
really pretty happy to be here and do
the shara shara I work with you and your
audience it's really really wonderful to
see or podcast spreading a message of
transhumanism getting a North Star
getting people thinking about what is
possible with exponential technologies
just so much they can be done today
ethical moral philosophical
transhumanism yes a business model
evolution yeah Thanks thank you so much
likewise thank you for hosting us been
wonderful yeah so some of the best
questions I've ever been asked here
thank you thank you and some of the best
strategies on tackling the most pressing
challenges yeah all team is doing the
best we can thank you that's all we can
do the best we can yeah that's right
banks have ruined for tuning in we
greatly appreciate it we'd love to hear
her thoughts in the comments below let
us know should thinking we would love to
hear from you about all the things that
Ben was teaching us about AI emotion
technologies using human data to
optimize human performance let us know
what you're thinking check out Alice
Holdings doll fund check out neuro tech
XCOM also check out Ben's profile
LinkedIn reach out to him if you want to
partake and any of the things that he's
been talking about reach out also
support the artists the entrepreneurs
the spiritual leaders organizations in
your communities that you believe in and
around the world you support simulation
our links are below to our show PayPal
patreon currency design cool where
should be paid keep supporting us so you
can do things like coming on site
interviewed people like Ben and go and
build the future everyone manifest your
dreams into the world we love you very
much thank you for tuning in we will see
you soon that's so cool dude this
podcast is so fun that's really cool
work you're doing
[Music]
you
[Music]